Peter Brown here with a gamespot news
update well it looks like there's a new
member on the failing to deliver on your
kickstarter club everyone welcome the
stomping lands after raising one hundred
and fourteen thousand dollars from 4,400
backers having initially only asked for
20,000 development of the stopping lands
appears to have halted a year after the
Kickstarter was funded a first build of
the project was released by a steam
early access with the assurance by its
developer Alex bundoora that even though
the game is available development is
still in full force despite that
reassurance that message from made 2014
marks the final update on the game's
Kickstarter page now the game's artist
has quit the project after being unable
to establish contact with Pandora for
weeks Vlad constantino has said more
than a month has passed us today when I
received the last reply from Pandora
I've sent him five messages and haven't
gotten a single reply Constantino also
claimed that fund or owes him money and
that he can no longer continue to
support the stomping Lance he has now
moved on to another dinosaur related
project besides suspending fedoras
account Kickstarter doesn't plan to do
anything about fedora or in support of
the backers any bets on the next member
of the failing to deliver on your
Kickstarter club let us know in the
comments below and stay tuned to
gamespot com for more news